Hãy cười về nhân kỳ điểm bệnh về tắm năm 2020,
hành bệnh tháng 20, năm 2020,
hành bệnh tháng 20, đam hành gịt không chừng hai lắm.
Hôm nay, tổng bị thư tổ lắm và đoàn công thách chủ ơn
đã dùng qua dân hơn tượng đẹp anh hộ vl xí
tại đền thời xí trên trường định bình phổ vàng gị trang lịch xí quốc gia áng hộp.
Tổng bị thư tổ lắm và đoàn công tác, đã thành tính dông qua dân hơn
tổng nhớ bây tò lắm bết ở vô hạc chủ tỳ khu xí miếng
anh hùng dài phẩm dân tổng, nhà bán hoa kia sốt,
từ nếu đại tư phẩm in giáp,
người anh cả của côn độ nhân dân Việt Nam,
cùng các bộ chính xí thành điên xúc phòng,
dân công hòa tuyến, quân bà dân cả nước,
đã anh dụng chìm đấu hí xin,
làm nên chìm thẳng lượng lấy năm châu, chứng tổn địa cầu.
Tại nghĩa tra lịch xí quốc gia áng hộp,
tổng bị thư tổ lắm xúc động bệtò.
Đồng có vứa xương mấu của các anh hộng điên xí và nhân dân,
đã có phần quyết tháng yệt biết phổng,
mở ra chăng xứng mối hào hùng của rất tổn địa Nam,
tạm nền mong đưa đất nước tá phát triển.
Cô vì chính thẳng dài phẩm biệt Nam thúng nhất đất nước,
và tiến thẳng trong các cuộc bảo vệ đên giới,
đã đưa đất nước tá chương tổn,
và bình viện đến vinh viện đến vinh dân tổt tá.
Đưa đất nước tá mức và ra đoạn phát triển phổn vinh hạnh phúc,
đời đời dời dời ở công ơn của các anh hùng lửa xí.
Cũng trong ngày hôm nay,
tổn bị thú tôn lâm đã đến thăm và tạm coa ra đình cụ phạm văn gần
xí hâm mình nhìn chính chăm bà tư,
đã xí xuống tế phần biệt vinh phổng,
tương là tư đổi phó chính đấu đổi ám ổn biệt vinh phổ,
và bị thương năm mình nhìn chính chăm lâm tư,
đã tự kiện bố gôn mối phần chăm,
tổn bị thú tôn lâm trong cuộc phạm văn gần của nhiều xí hoài,
đã trở dựa tinh thần để có chào nói theo,
tiếp tục phát triển thủ tốt đẹp bộ độ của hồ,
dựa hại tinh thần,
chính xí đẹp biệt vinh lâm xóa hâm.